[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public 90
minutes de débat de chronique et de
reportage pour donner du sens à
l'actualité comme tous les soirs sur
Public Sénat les agriculteurs sont en
colère et ce mouvement d'une profession
en grande difficulté fait figure de
premier test à haut risque pour Gabriel
Atal comment le nouveau Premier ministre
peut-il désamorcer une crise qui trouve
notamment sa source dans la rigidité du
pacte vert européen est-ce le début
d'une révolte incontrôlable qui
rappellerait celle des gilets jaunes on
en débat dans une minute et puis dans
tris quarts d'heure direction la mer
Rouge ù les rebelles yeménites outil
visent les navires marchants depuis
plusieurs semaines des attaques
soutenues par
l'Iran hier nous avons eu l'attaque de
drone la plus importante ces attaques
ont été soutenues et encouragées par
l'Iran en terme de technologie
d'équipement de renseignement et
d'information les Américains et leurs
alliés britanniques ont riposté contre
les installations militaires des outils
mais les attaques persistent qui sont
ces rebelles chites adept d'un islam
rigoriste sont-ils le bras armé des
Molas iraniens comment permettre au
commerce mondial de reprendre
normalement dans la région ne ratez pas
les explications de nos experts tout à
l'heure mais d'abord les blocages des
agriculteurs qui continuent un peu
partout en Europe et notamment en France
sur laa64 entre Toulouse et Bayonne
Mathias Arz la colère du monde agricole
gronde en France mais aussi ailleurs en
Europe les manifestations se sont
multipliées ces derniers jours comme ici
entre Toulouse et Bayonne où plusieurs
dizaines d'exploitants bloquent depuis
jeudi soir l'autoroute à
64 nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
on rentre en action et je peux vous dire
que dès aujourd'hui et toute la semaine
et aussi longtemps qu' qu'il sera
nécessaire un certain nombre d'actions
vont être menées des actions qui
poussent l'exécutif à revoir sa copie
initialement prévu ce mercredi en
Conseil des ministres la présentation du
projet de loi sur l'installation des
agriculteurs est de nouveau reporté on
va voir dans les jours et dans les
semaines qui viennent puisqueils l'ont
dit eux-même ils souhaitent formuler un
certain nombre de propositions et donc à
partir de ces propos là construisons il
y a parfois des des organisations
syndicales parfois des sujets de filière
sur lesquel il faut qu'on travaille il
me semble que chacun doit se mettre au
travail au rassemblement national on
entend capitaliser sur cette colère
Jordane Bardella président du parti et
tête de liste aux Européennes était
samedi au côté de vitulteur dans le
Médoc et le point commun de ce mouvement
de colère c'est l'Union européenne et
l'Europe de
Macron qui veut la mort de notre
agriculture qui ne cesse de la mettre en
concurrence avec des produits agricole
qui viennent du bout du monde un sujet
abrasif que le premier ministre Gabriel
hatal a décidé de prendre
personnellement en main la profession
attend du gouvernement des mesures
concrètes notamment en matière de
charges financières de normes
environnementales mais aussi de hausse
du prix de
l'électricité comment le gouvernement
peut-il calmer la colère des
agriculteurs quels sont quelles seront
les conséquence politique de ce
mouvement on en débat avec Philippe
chalmain bonsoir bonsir bienvenue vous
êtes économiste professeur à Paris
Dauphine spécialiste des matières
premières Laurence deerve bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes la directrice du
cercle de réflexion destin commun
Richard verli bonsoir bienvenue à vous
correspondant France Europe pour le
média Suisse blique et j'accueille
Mathieu croissant d'au bonsoir Mathieu
éditorialist politique ce ralbol des
agriculteurs Philippe chalmain quel est
le terme que qui vous vient spontanément
pour le qualifier généraliser peut-être
écoutez c'est au-delà de ce qui a
provoqué problème problèm sanitair
problèm de maladie chez les bovins plus
ou moins bien indemnisés et cetera de
lenteur c'est vous venez de le dire
c'est un ralebol complet ralebol
peut-être un peu en terme de revenus
beaucoup en terme de complexité des
règles des normes de toute cette
pesanteur qui s'abat sur la vie
quotidienne des agriculteurs française
et européen française et européenne
alors ça soyons honnête le génie
bureaucratique à la française a fait son
nit dans le Maqui européen et il est
arrivé quand même à des résultats
souvent d'une assez grande complexité il
faut le reconnaître et puis il y a aussi
cette réaction à l'agribashing parmi
quasi permanent où finalement on montre
du doigt les agriculteurs que ce soit
les écolos que ce soit les tenants tout
à fait
légitimes de la lutte contre le
changement climatique et cetera en
disant aux agriculteurs vous sentez
mauvais vous polluez et quand les
agriculteurs font des efforts et qui
disent ben on va faire du bio on va
faire de l'agriculture raisonnée et
cetera ah oui mais les consommateurs ne
sont pas prêt à en payer la différence
et on en voit bien là les conséquences
par exemple avec la crise du bio on
touche les limites de de l'équation
laurenceerv sur cette Agri ou
agrobaching est-ce qu'il est pratiqué
par beaucoup de Français quel quel à
quel niveau peut-on le situer dans la
société française non justement je pense
que c'est un paradoxe de de la crise que
que nous que nous observons aujourd'hui
c'est que l'agribaching en fait n'est
pas du tout le fait de la majorité des
Français les agriculteurs continuent de
jouir d'une de la du soutien de la
sympathie d'une grande majorité des
Français ils ont une bonne image auprès
de la majorité avec un décalage
intéressant qui est que entre 80 et 90 %
des Français ont en général une bonne
image des agriculteurs et seulement
entre 50 et 60 % des agriculteurs
pensent que les Français ont une bonne
image d'eux voyez ce ce sentiment de
désamour voilà à quoi est-il dû mais
sans doute au fait que ils se sentent
effectivement écrasé et pas compris pas
pas entendu pas représenté non plus on
sait que ils se sentent mal représentés
par leur représentants c'est-à-dire les
les les syndicats en l'occurrence et
puis parce que aussi il y a des
scandales parfois à juste titre ou
souvent à juste titre qui sont fortement
médiatisés ça participe aussi d'une
d'une image dégradée tout à fait mais en
tout cas les Français sont conscients
que les agriculteurs sont en première
ligne dans la transition écologique qui
est un défi dont ils sont largement
conscients et qu'ils soutiennent dans
lequel les Français souhaitent s'engager
oui tien mais peut-être pas jusqu'au
portefeuille avec avec un souci d'équité
je pense que c'est ça qui est au cœur de
leur préoccupation je vrais juste Thomas
H vient de dire les scandales vous
pensiez à quoi des scandales
alimentaires les scandales de de
l'agroalimentaire oui alors écoutez
jamais les Français n'ont aussi bien
mangé du point de vue qualitatif oui et
jamais par contre il n a eu
effectivement autant de peurs
alimentaires ne croyez pas qu'au début
du 20e siècle alors que l'espérance de
vie moyenne des Français était de
l'ordre de 50 ans que l'on mangeait mal
ne cro
pas il a un effet loupe peut-être estil
médiatique mais il y a un effet loupe
sur les scandales quand il y en a ils
existentexagérons
pas je pense qu' un aging de CAD ENF de
charot peut-être pas dans la perception
mais le fait est que la moitié de ce que
les gens achète dans les rayons des
supermarchés est importé ce sont pas il
y a pas de rFlex made in France pour
agriculture parce qu'on
demande on demande aux agriculteurs oui
pris en compte mais on leur demande de
voilà d'avoir de la bonne bouffe versus
la malbouffe on leur demande de
respecter l'environnement d'être des
gardiens d'environnement on leur demande
de tout faire à faible cout c'est une
équation qui n'est pas tenable les trois
la FO les injonction contradictoire
Richard verli c'est un mouvement
européen il faut peut-être jeter un
petit coup d'œil dans le dans le rétro
il y a 10 mois Pays-Bas élection
sénatoriale il y a y a un coup de tonner
qu'il faut rappeler là tout de suite au
début de ce débat l'ironie d'ailleurs
c'est que ça a démarré au Pays-Bas dans
un pays qui est le champion de
l'agroindustrie donc au Pays-Bas ce sont
pas des petits exploitants ruraux de
régions éloignéés qui ont battu le pavé
c'est vraiment des grandes entreprises
agricoles et qui elles-même alors qu'on
pensait que l'Europe allait soutenir ces
entreprises là même ces entreprises que
j'appelle agro-industriell se sentent en
danger se sentent menacé donc pour
répondre à votre question tout à l'heure
Thomas vous disiez un mot pour moi c'est
l'angoisse c'est un un segment de la
population française et européenne qui
est en angoissé sur son existence sur
son devenir d'abord en raison de la
complexité administrative on l'a dit
mais surtout parce que le revenu n'est
plus au rendez-vous les vocations ne
sont plus au rendez-vous le nombre de
suicides on le sait en France à un
moment donné en disant on disait qu'il y
avait un suicide d'agriculteur tous les
de jours voilà exactement je ne sais pas
j'espère que ce chiffre n'est plus vrai
aujourd'hui en 2024 malheureusement il
rest il reste et puis il y a une autre
chose qui est à mon avis très
révélatrice c'est que l'agriculture
n'est plus n'est jamais cité dans les
forces de l'Europe aujourd'hui il y a un
problème de représentativité même
symbolique l'Europe elle parle
d'industrie de la défense en gros on
n'arrête pas de nous dire qu'il faut
produire des obus on sait pourquoi c'est
une bonne idée mais on ne nous dit
jamais qu'il faut aussi produire des
cultures pour nourrir les gens je
faisais référence au sénatorial
néerlandaise un un parti sorti un peu
nulle part le mouvement agriculteur
citoyen qui remporte 15
sièges à ces élections
sénatorialesthie juste là-dessus c'est
intéressant parce que le le en fait les
raisons de la colère des agriculteurs
sont différentes selon les pays au
Pays-Bas que vous venez de citer c'est
ce qu'ils appellent le plan azote était
la réduction des cheptels pour éviter
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
Allemagne chez nos voisins ce sont les
taxes sur le gazol agricole et une taxe
qui avait été envisagée sur les
tracteurs qui a mis le feu en poudre en
Espagne c'est une histoire de
détournement de cours d'eau pour
irriguer ou pas on voit bien que les
raisons elles sont protéiformes mais
elles aboutissent une même colre le
point commun c'est la mutation de Laure
le point commun c'est quand même le
pacte vert européen VO euh le grand
architecte d'ailleurs du pacte vert
c'était monsieur Timmermans et et c'est
lui qui a abandonné son poste à la
Commission pour essayer de mener son
parti à la victoire au Pays-Bas et qui a
été battu et effectivement le le plan
azote des Pays-Bas c'était une
application à la serpe d'un pacte vert
qui s'il était appliqué à merait à ce
que la production agricole européenne se
diminue de 15 % et qu'à ce moment-là la
part des importations dont vous parlez
bien elle aurait d'autant plus augmenté
pour l'instant l'Europe reste quand même
une exportatrice nette de céréales de
viande bovine euh d'un certain nombre de
d'oléagineux et cetera donc il y a
encore un certain nombre de points où
nous avons des niveaux d'excellence sans
même parler du 20 lui-même pourtant en
crise comme la a montré la visite de
Bardella à Bordeaux 20 Bordeaux est dans
une sombre crise à l'heure actuelle avec
des plans de de d'arrachage de de de
vigne en prévision alors il y a la
question effment vous c'est c'est ce que
vous avez cité en premier d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure la question du du revenu
tout simplement des agriculteurs
aujourd'hui écoutez cet éleveur il
cultive aussi des céréales il fait
partie de de celles et ceux qui bloquent
l'autoroute A64 entre Toulouse et
Bayonne
problème dans le monde agricole c'est
c'est le revenu agcole qui qui baisse de
plus en plus on achète toujours plus
cher nos int notre matériel et on vend
toujours moins cher d'un moment ça
coince et c'est vécu comme une
injustice ça mène à de la colère y a un
problème de
rentabilité on est vraiment la la
variable
d'ajustement par rapport au au
distributeurs et aux
industriels on n' pas la main là-dessus
et euh moi ce que ce que j'attendrais
c'est c'est que qu'il soit légiféré
là-dessus voilà le blocage de cette
autoroute on va voir quelques images de
cette autoroute à 64 continuer ce ce
lundi il y a d'autres mouvements dans
d'autres régions françaises euh Laurence
Nervo est-ce qu'on peut faire est-ce que
vous faites un parallèle avec le
mouvement des gilets jaunes bien sûr que
le parallèle entre les gilets jaunes et
les gilets verts il n'est pas du tout
absurde puisque on voit que les lieux de
rassemblement et de mobilisation sont
les mêmes ce sont les bloc routier ce
sont les rond-points également les lieux
de passage les slogans également sont
comparables hein la France qui marche
qui la la tête à l'envers on crève on
veut vivre de notre travail les et puis
le fait qu'évidemment un des sujets qui
a mis fait au poudre c'est une question
autour des du prix des carburants là
aussi il y a également une sociologie
qui est comparable
indéiablement néanmoins le mouvement
n'est pas le même puisque là il est
évidemment sectoriel et il est euh du
coup centré sur une série de
revendications sectorielles donc le fait
qu'il puisse s'étendre se généraliser à
d'autres professions est moins moins
envisageable sans doute Richard verlier
est-ce que vous croyez à un mouvement
similaire un peu incontrôlable puis que
c'était unee des caractéristiques du
mouvement des gilets jaunes alors non et
je viens d'ailleurs d'écrire un papier
pour dire que je n'y croyais pas alors
j'espère queire j'espère que les faits
ne vont pas me démentir non j'y crois
pas pour deux raisons essentielles
d'abord parce que les les manifestations
de paysans sur les ronds-points j'en ai
pas vu tant que ça c'était des des
points de rassemblement moment donc la
symbolique des r et populations sont pas
du tout les mêmes rappelez-vous à
l'époque des gilets jaunes il y avait
pas eu de solidarité des paysans avec le
mouvement des gilets jaunes et il y
avait beaucoup de paysans qui d'ailleurs
n'aimaient pas tellement les gilets
jaunes parce que c'était une population
les gilets jaunes de petite classe
moyenne populaire des villes moyennes
qui manifestaient donc je crois que
c'est pas du tout la même chose et même
si les paysans sont disons en colère
contre leurs représentants ils sont
néanmoins très canalisés il y a des
organisations syndicales qui sont fortes
et ces organisations syndicales elles
ont montré dans le passé qu'elles savent
comment
ça m'intéresse de savoir ce que vous en
pensez mais mais quand même Richard
verli ce qui ce qu' a en commun c'est
peut-être la leçon que le
gouvernement tire des gilets jaunes dans
sa façon de réagir là le plus vite
possible en dépêchant les préfets sur le
terrain et et je parle sous le contrôle
de Philippe qui connaît bien les
histoires de de cours et d'agriculture
ça m'étonnerait beaucoup que sur ce
coupci Emmanuel Macron s'en sorte avec
un grand débat national avec les paysans
je crois que c'est pas ce que demandent
les paysans les gilets jaunes ils ont
accepté ce grand débat national ce
cahier de doléance au niveau des
communes qui par ailleurs a été un
succès mais dont on a peut tenir compte
si je me souviens il a un
1 il y a eu le dé national et le chèque
il me semble que dans ce cas de figure
les paysans ils veulent des mesures
concrètes et encore une fois ils savent
comment faire l'histoire a montré que
ils savent à quelle porte frapper
Philippe chal sur sur le les syndicats
principaux syndicats agricoles et
ont-ils ou non la main sur ce mouvement
est-ce que ce mouvement leur échappe en
partie alors le mouvement est parti euh
sans qu'ils aient la main dessus il n'en
reste pas moins que euh pour situer vous
avez trois grands syndicats agricoles le
syndicat d' majoritaire FNSEA cngja la
Coordination Rurale un petit peu plus à
droite le Confédération paysane un petit
peu plus à gauche euh avec souvent
notamment pour la Confédération paysane
des positions qui sont d'ailleurs des
positions un peu ambigu puisque la
Confédération paysane a par exemple
soutenu tous les écologes les problèmes
des bassines en Vendé et cetera ce qui
entre nous était d'une absurdité totale
puisque un des problèmes justement celui
de l'accès à l'eau mais je suis comme
Richard j'aurait tendance à penser que
oui c'est bien de dire gilet jaune gilet
vert ça n'ira pas tellement plus loin
maintenant je ne vois pas tellement
quelles peuvent être les marges de
manœuvre du gouvernement parce que
autant on est tous d'accord simplifier
c'est une évidence c'est très facile à
dire c'est très compliqué à faire
l'autre revendication c'est le revenu or
il y a une chose sur lequel il faut
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
lorsqu'on dit avec la loi égalime on va
sauver le revenu des agriculteurs c'est
une escroquerie intellectuelle puisque
le revenus des agriculteurs il dépend de
quoi il dépend des prix agricoles et les
pris agricoles il se forme non pas dans
la négociation avec l'industrie et les
distribution il se forme sur les marchés
européens sur les marchés mondiaux et
donc quelque part personne aujourd'hui
n'a plus la main sur la formation des
prêts agricoles deux thèmes dans votre
intervention c'est très intéressant on
va d'abord parler de la réponse possible
du gouvernement et puis dans un instant
tiens je vous propose qu'on qu'on le
voit tout de suite on sera en duplexe
avec Nicolas Chaban le le fondateur de
squil patron qui justement s'est fondé
en 2016 après une première crise sur le
sur le le revenu agricole je simplifie
un petit peu et qui cherche et qui
réussit je crois à mieux rémunérer les
agriculteurs on sera avec vous dans dans
un court instant Nicolas Chaban mais
Mathieu c'est quand même intéressant là
on se pose la question de l'évolution du
mouvement gilet jaune gilet vert ça
ressemble quand même à une première
épreuve du feu pour Gabriel Atal ah bah
oui HE 15 jours après sa nomination
voilà déjà le Premier ministre dans le
dur hein et les épreuves qui s'annoncent
ne serait-ce que cette semaine euh
au-delà de la la révolte des
agriculteurs dont on va parler et ben ça
ressemble à des cassetettes Chinois
d'abord donc cette colère des
agriculteurs typiquement le genre de
mouvement infernal pour un gouvernement
avec des gens qui n'ont plus rien à
perdre on l'a dit des revendication
extrêmement disparate et difficile à
satisfaire on en a parlé aussi un
soutien de l'opinion publique un
calendrier serré je rappelle qu'il y a
quand même le salon de l'agriculture
dans un mois et des européennes dans 5
mois on peut ajouter pour compléter le
tableau on verra mais peut-être un
divorce entre la base et les
représentants syndicaux ça s'est passé
un peu en Allemagne donc on peut
rappeler que en France la FNSEA elle est
dirigée par quelqu'un qui est président
du groupe ail un géant désoléagineux qui
a pas grand chose à voir avec les gens
qu'on voit faire le barrage sur
l'autoroute en Occitanie hein on peut
ajouter en plus une opposition qui
souffle sur les braises bien sûr et puis
des caisses de l'État qui sont vides un
contexte européen pour dont on a parlé
de révolte paysane un ministre qui a été
reconduit à son poste mais qui est un
peu démonétisé dans la profession parce
que il y avait une loi qui avait été
promise et qui n'a pas vu le jour
promise à l'ut 2022 repousser au
printemps 2023 puis à l'automne 2023
puis hier il arrive ce ministre sur un
plateau télé et la première chose qu'
annon c'est ben je repousse la loi pour
la compléter avec des nouvelles mesures
ça fait pas quand même très très
crédible moi je vous entends je dis on a
pas envie d'être à la place de ah B non
non jeis plus et puis le ralbol d'normme
en fait avancé par les agriculteurs va
placer le nouveau Premier ministre
devant un premier dilemme cornélien
l'environnement ou les paysans si on
simplifie he mais comme dirait l'autre
gouverner c'est choisir et d'une
certaine façon souvenez-vous le
président a déjà un peut donner le là
c'était en mai dernier il avait réclamé
une pause dans la réglementation
européenne notamment environnmentale
alors on va sortir un tout petit peu
quoique parce que ça concerne aussi les
agriculteurs autre difficulté pour le
gouvernement l'augmentation des tarifs
de l'électricité oui ça c'est le second
dilemme le pouvoir d'achat ou les
finances de l'État alors celui-ci a déjà
été tranché ce dilemme là et pour pas
donner le sentiment que la première
mesure du nouveau Premier ministre était
une punition ben c'est Bruno Le Maire le
ministre de l'économie qui s'est chargé
hier sur TF1 d'annoncer la mauvaise
nouvelle un dimanche soir h comme ça en
espérant qu'on y voit pas plus que ça
mais euh l'opposition s'est aussitôt
engouffrée dans la brèche que ce soit la
gauche ou que ce soit la droite et ou
l'extrême droite et puis un autre c-etê
aussi pour Gabriel troisième cass-etête
vous le devinez on en a beaucoup parlé
sur ce plateau ça pourrait se résumer à
une alternative c'est à propos de Amélie
oua Castera Stop ou Encore elle a été
confortée par le Président de la
République la semaine dernière mais la
ministre de l'éducation doit affronter
deux nouvelles polémiques une sur son
fils qui aurait bénéficié d'une forme de
passe droit sur parcours coursu pour
être pris en prépa à sanislas et puis
maintenant ses émoluments lorsqu'elle
dirigeait la Fédération Française de
Tennis qui sont mis sur le devant de la
scène s'il la lâche Gabriel Atal ben
d'une certaine façon il perd la face
mais s'il la conserve à son poste il
risque de perdre toute possibilité de
réforme avec des syndicats qui ne
veulent plus parler à leur ministre pas
facile non plus comme dilemme ouis et
puis on parlait de Jordan Bardella il y
a aussi les élections européennes en en
point de M voilà et là il y a un dernier
dilemme qui arrive jeudi jeudi c'est
quoi c'est le retour du triste
feuilleton de la loi immigr avec la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel qui
est attendu après s'être fâché sur sa
gauche ben l'exécutif qui s'attend à ce
que le Conseil constitutionnel pardon
censure une bonne partie de du projet de
loi mais pourrait se fâcher sur sa
droite et sur son extrême droite ce qui
manquerait pas de provoquer la colère
DLR et du rassemblement national de quoi
rendre encore un peu plus inflammable
les 5 mois qui nous séparent du scrutin
européen je reviens à la colère agricole
merci Matthieu qui est le cœur de notre
débat Richard verli on l'a dit un test
pour Gabriel àal est-ce qu'il a vraiment
les leviers pour agir le Premier
ministre il a deux difficultés majeures
la première c'est que la crédibilité du
gouvernement en matière agricole elle
n'est pas au rendez-vous les
agriculteurs n'ont pas confiance en
Emmanuel Macron pour les raisons qui ont
été évoqué rappelons juste que lorsque
la négociation du pacte vert le fameux
green dealo Parlement européen a eu lieu
l'un des leaders à défendre le pacte
verse n'était autre que Pascal campfin
l'un des chefs de fil du groupe
Renaissance c'est-à-dire du groupe
présidentiel
h comment on a fait voter comment la
majorité actuelleit voter à Strasbourg
unexte le Green Deal défavorable aux
agriculteurs français mais queon est
quand même pour l'agriculture française
ça va être très compliqué en même temps
en même temps si l'on peut dire et le
deuxème obstacle c'est évidemment qu'en
matière agricole en réalité en terme de
régulation et de norme il faut tout de
suite appeler décrocher le téléphone et
dire allô Bruxelles et vous imaginez
bien qu'en ce moment la Commission
européenne elle est décimée un certain
nom de commissaires sont déjà en
campagne madame Mame V deren ne pense
qu'à sa réélection donc quand vous
décrochez le téléphone et que vous
appelez àô Bruxelles personne ne répond
alors vous avez évoqué la question de la
rémunération de la juste rémunération
des des agriculteurs comme promis on est
avec Nicolas Chaban qui est le fondateur
de c'estquil patron bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté de participer pendant
quelques minutes à à ce débat donc vous
l'aviez créé en 2016 avec d'autres
consommateurs engagés c'était déjà la la
crise pour pour les agriculteurs là vous
dites quoi rien n'a changé comment vous
réagissez en ce moment
non ça ça vraiment on n jamais ressenti
nous ça fait 20 ans qu'on est au côté
des producteurs en tant que consommateur
on na jamais vu ce
niveau d'urgence et de de
colère c'est lié d'ailleurs au fait que
les producteurs vous le savez tous sur
ce plateau ils ont tendance vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure à pas manifester
autant que d'autres il y a un côté un
peu une forme de fierté on on ne raconte
pas ses problèmes ça donne des drames
avec un suicide par jour en France euh
et là il faut imaginer que cette colère
elle est pas contextuelle euh elle est
profonde elle vient de très loin
euh si euh à un mois du salon
d'agriculture tout le monde se retrouve
dans la rue avec cette détermination
c'est que les problèmes sont polymorphes
il y en a à tous les niveaux et
notamment la rémunération des
producteurs euh c'est quand même la
seule profession de France où vous
travaillez et où on vous dit notamment
dans le lait à la fin du mois écoutez ça
sera finalement cette rémunération là et
pas celle que vous imaginiez c'est
absolument incroyable pour nous
consommateur en 2024 les gens qui nous
nourrissent et qui nourrissent nos
enfants n'ai pas plus de visibilité sur
leur métier vous l'avez dit ensuite les
plus jeunes ne s'installent pas inter
jeend je reprends la main pardon vous
interrompre Nicolas Chavan mais comment
vous faites pour mieux rémunérer les
agriculteurs qui travaillent avec vous
il y a moins d'intermédiaire c'est ça la
logique nous on a une coopérative de
consommateur on a créé un lait le jour o
on a découvert qu'il manquait 8 centimes
par litre pour qu'un producteur vive de
son métier euh c'est devenu bah cette
brique de lait peut-être vous connaissez
voilà Leit c'est qui le patron ce lait
il rémunère à juste pris le producteur
parce que c'est lui qui le décide on a
fait trois réévaluations de sa
rémunération parce que c'est le
producteur qui décide qui dit à nous
consommateurs j'ai des
chargesélectricité le fou je dois gagner
de plus en plus elle est devenue cette
brique de lait alors qu'elle peut
paraître un peu hors de du système et de
la logique des 40 ans du monde
agroalimentaire elle est devenue la
brique de lait la plus vendue de France
devant Lactel devant
Candia pourquoi parce que comment vous
répercutez dernière question dernière
question comment vous répercutez
l'inflation ça veut dire qu'elle a
augmenté là récemment de cette brique de
lait ouais absolument elle était à 99
centimes elle est à 1,27 mais
contrairement à bien d'autres
initiatives on a pu expliquer où sont
passés les 28 centimes c'est la
transparence qui manque pour aider les
producteurs les 28 centimes il y en a eu
15 vers les producteurs 13 vers la laie
il y a pas eu de centime vers les
distributeurs ou vers l'initiative la
coopérative de consommateurs et vous
savez ce qui s'est passé pour finir je
vous laisse à votre débat après le
marché du lait avec l'inflation a baissé
de 3 % cette brique de lait c'est 100
millions de ventes par an elle a
augmenté de 5,9 % donc il y a peut-être
un espoir pour nous consommateurs et
pour les producteurs dites-nous où va
notre argent et on protège les
producteurs avec d'autant plus plaisir
qu'on est sûr que ça leur redonne le
merci beaucoup Nicolas Chaban Philippe
chalmain est-ce que c'est possible de
généraliser un modèle comme celui-là non
pourquoi et je dirais même que le cas
dans le domaine du lait
n'est tient la route je dirais par son
exception il faut savoir que c'est très
facile vous imaginez que le lait qui
sort du P de la vache il est il va
directement dans le joli tétrab
c'est moi c'est qui patron et ceter le
monde du lait il est beaucoup plus
complexe puisque à partir de votre
brique de de votre lait vous faites
certes du lait UHT demi écrémé mais vous
produisez de la crème avec cette crème
vous pouvez faire du beurre et cetera
donc vous avez finalement un cracking du
lait qui est extrêmement complexe et
comme la France et l'Europe sont
excédentaires sont exportatrices de lait
de poudre de lait nous dépendons aussi
des marchés mondiaux l'année dernière
Cyclope que je dirige sort demain son
bilan des marchés en 2023 l'année
dernière en prix moyen les prix au
niveau international du beurre et de la
poudre ont ont diminué de 20 à 25 %. euh
dans un cas extrême en Nouvelle-Zélande
le le quasi monopole de la production de
lait en Nouvelle-Zélande qui est une
coopérative fonté
a diminué son prix du lait au producteur
de 29 %. bon alors ça c'est extrême
parce que les néozélandais ils ont un
tout petit marché intérieur et ils
exportent énormément de matières
premières laitières le monde du lait est
un monde particulièrement opaque et là
où Nicolas Chaban a raison c'est que on
aurait dû et ça fait longtemps que l'on
devrait rentrer dans des logiques de
contractualisation mais et de
transparence je je reprends la main je
va vous donner la par les prix sont
transparents et ce que je disais tout à
l'heure malheureusement aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le gouvernement ce n'est pas
Bruxelles qui font les prix le prix du
blé a été diminué par deux par rapport
au pic atteint au lendemain de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine c'est un marché
mondial comme le marché du comme marché
du poudre
et gouvernement ne peut pas faire des
prix et je suis désolé quand je vois et
vous vous avez employé le terme de Juste
Prix de juste rémunération sur le plan
de la morale je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous en tant qu'économiste
je vous dis je ne sais pas ce qu'est un
juste prix parce que au fond un prix à
un moment donné c'est la rencontre entre
une offre et une demande ça n'est ni
juste ni injuste bon allez euh les
européennes on a commencé à en parler il
y a il y a un instant on va y consacrer
plusieurs minutes dans ce débat avec
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
forcément euh plusieurs partis
politiques qui montent au créneau c'est
leur rôle dans un contexte comme
celui-là avec une crise qui démarre et
notamment Jordane Bardella qui pointe du
doigt la responsabilité de l'Union
européenne on l'écoute le monde agricole
lui est important pour la France et on
entend pas le laisser mourir dans
l'indifférence généralisée je pense
qu'il y a un mouvement de colère qui est
en train de se lever aujourd'hui partout
en Europe et le point commun de ce
mouvement de colère c'est l'Union
européenne et l'Europe de
Macron qui veut la mort euh de notre
agriculture euh qui ne cesse de la
mettre en concurrence avec des produits
agricoles qui viennent du bout du monde
et Steve jourain nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir Steve on l'entend
beaucoup de critiques contre la pack la
politique agricole commune la France
est-elle si mal l'auti en matière
d'aides européennes non la France est la
première puissance agricole en Europe et
à ce titre la plus grosse bénéficiaire
de la PAC il faut savoir que
l'agriculture est le premier poste de
dépenses de l'Union européenne c'est
environ un/ers de son budget chaque
année l'Europe distribue plus de 50
milliards d'euros entre les États
membres la France touche elle plus de 9
milliards d'euros par an c'est 17 % du
budget de la PAC devant l'Espagne et
l'Allemagne la nouvelle politique
agricole est entrée en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2023 elle court jusqu'en 2027 et
sur la période la France obtiendra 45
milliards d'euros reste à répartir cet
argent entre les agriculteurs ouais
c'est là que ça se complique hein chaque
pays souhaite avoir la main sur sa
politique agricole l'Union européenne
fixe des objectifs environnementaux et
économiques à charge ensuite pour les
états de les décliner sur leur
territoire en fonction évidemment de
leurs priorités le cadre au niveau
européen c'est le pacte vert l'Europe a
adopté une feuille de route pour aboutir
à la neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 les
objectifs de la PAC doivent se plier à
cet impératif il est prévu notamment et
bien d'accorder des primes aux
agriculteurs qui participent à des
programmes environnementaux plus
exigeants à ceux qui ont recours à des
techniques plus écologiques
et à ceux qui ont qui contribuent à
améliorer le bien-être animal comment
tout ceci se décline en France al plus
de 400000 agriculteurs français
bénéficient de ces aides leur revenus
dépend parfois intégralement de ce
soutien direct le niveau d'aide varie
selon les les efforts fournis en matière
de bonnes pratiques environnementales
les fonds sont distribués selon des
impératifs qui sont fixés dans un plan
national on va voir quelques mesures en
vraque il existe notamment un soutien à
la conversion vers l'agriculture
biologique ça passe par des subventions
aux agriculteurs qui se convertissent au
bio alors que l'objectif est un
doublement de de la surface qui est
consacré à ce type d'agriculture d'ici à
2027 il y a aussi une aide aux
agriculteurs qui font des efforts pour
limiter les l'érosion des sols et une
récompense au renoncement aux pesticides
il y a enfin et c'est très important
Thomas une aide à l'installation des
jeunes on parle d'une enveloppe de 200
millions d'euros les jeunes qui son
posent aujourd'hui beaucoup de questions
sur leur avenir dans un contexte de
concurrence internationale merci merci
beaucoup Steve Jourdain pour toutes ces
informations Laurence deerveau je
reviens vers vous peut-être
sur ce que les les Français attendent de
l'Europe en matière en matière
d'agriculture d'alimentation si je
simplifie oui nous venons de publier une
étude qualitative sur les attentes des
Français vis-à-vis de l'Europe à 6 mois
un petit pe cétait il y a 6 mois
maintenant on est plus proche de
l'chanceces c'est le 9 juin prochain en
fait les attentes des Français sur les
questions environnemental et climatique
peuvent se résumer autour du tripticque
boire manger respirer c'est très clair
et la priorité numéro 1 c'est
l'alimentation ils nous ont beaucoup dit
et les Français font le lien entre
l'alimentation et l'agriculture ils le
disent eux même derrière il y a des gens
qui en vivent c'est comme ça qu'il le
disait donc la préoccupation sociale des
Français au du point de vue des des
enjeux de la transition écologique est
très élevée et donc pour revenir à ce
que disait Mathieu croissand tout à
l'heure est-ce que le gouvernement va
devoir choisir entre l'environnement et
les paysans clairement pas il va falloir
joindre les de bouts et je pense que il
y a aussi des enjeux on a vu hein la la
longue liste des aides des sub
al Ry va peutêtre pas ass vite il y a
aussi des enjeux de communication de
cadrage c'estàd que aujourd'hui dans la
situation qui est celle de nos
agriculteurs il n'est pas audible de
parler de la disparition des oiseaux des
champs sans tenir compte d'abord du fait
qu'il y a un agriculteur qui se suicide
un jour sur deux il n'est sans doute pas
non plus souhaitable de parler de la de
la hausse du prix de leur des carburant
de leur tracteur quand ce sont des
personnes qui travaillent 70 heur par
semaine pour des salaires de misère et
quand à côté ces personnes voient que on
n'avance pas sur la taxation du carosè
des avions ou voilà sur d'autres sujets
de société qui ont fait débats ces
derniers mois ces derniers mois en fait
ces enjeux de justice sociale et
d'équité sont au cœur des préoccupations
des Français et euh les il peuvent les
les irriter très fortement et je pense
que la question de l'opinion va bien sûr
être un paramètre central dans la
gestion de cette crise par Gabriel Atal
dans les jours et dans les semaines qui
viennent et et pardon vous interrom je
complète ma question par le niveau de
défiance des Français alors peut-être
plus générale vis-à-vis de l'Union
européenne il est élevé clairement il
est il se double d'une grande
méconnaissance c'était l'enseignement
majeur de notre étude on a appelé ça
élection européenne le grand brouillard
les Français dans leur majorité ne sont
pas au courant que nous allons élire les
prochains députés au Parlement européen
en juin prochain et ils ont un sentiment
de grand flou de grande de grande
confusion il ne il méconnaissent très
largement le fonctionnement des
institutions européennes et précisément
le pacte vert dont il est beaucoup
questions ces jour-ci au sujet des
agriculteurs toutes les personnes que
nous avons interrogé n'en avaient jamais
entendu parler que que l'on parle de
Green Deal de pacte vert d'agenda vert
c'était le blackout total donc il faut
en parler davantage il faut expliquer
faire la pédagogie comme ça vient d'être
fait à l'instant de ce que ce pacte vert
comprend pour ne pas laisser le
rassemblement national en faire une
pédagogie mensongeère et opportuniste et
s'engouffrer dans cette brèche
relativement facile voilà bien sûr il
est plus facile de jouer en attaque
qu'en défense he
ouai mais Richard ver il y a des
critiques à exprimer sur ce pacte vert
oui Dee manière il y a une vulnérabilité
d'Emmanuel Macron sur ce sujet comme je
le disais parce que le fait est que le
groupe Renaissance le groupe macroniste
au Parlement européen a voté ces textes
il a même ardemment milité pour ce texte
du CREN deal donc il vaut falloir que le
président s'en explique c'est un peu
pareil d'ailleurs avec les classes
moyennes lors de la conférence de presse
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron a dit
qu'il allait se battre pour les classes
moyennes mais si vous demandez aux
classes moyenne qu'est-ce qui les a
paupérisé ces dernières années beaucoup
de gens vont vous répondre l'Europe et
les réglementations européennes donc là
il y a pour le coup un angle mort c'est
l'expression qu' avit utilisé Emmanuel
Macron à propos des classes moyennes il
y a un angle mort de la politique
macroniste c'està-dire que défendre la
souveraineté européenne c'est une bonne
chose mais il faut voir que ça a des
conséquences pour un certain nombre de
catégories sociales ensuite la grande
difficulté c'est que pour l'instant mais
ça pourrait changer il n'y avait pas de
de de capacité je dirais européenne il
n'y avait pas de front commun pour
rediscuter les sujets écologistes et les
sujets de climat moi je crois qu'il faut
faire attention c'est pas parce qu'il y
a un Green Deal aujourd'hui qu'il va
être intact dans les 15 ans à venir et
que personne va le va le retoucher si
les gouvernements changent si les
majorité change on peut renégocier des
choses au niveau européen parce que
l'Europe est quand même en train de se
rendre compte que tous ces engagements
climatiques qui sont extrêmement
vertueux ne lui rapporte pas grand-chose
ouais est-ce que c'est un boulet est-ce
que ça deviendra un atout vraie CHR bah
le pire est à venir parce que que il n'a
pas encore commencé à s'appliquers ce
Pact faut le dire les mesures n'ont pas
encore commencé à s'appliquer donc tous
les gens qui disent les les les
agriculteurs on aa le bol du pacte vert
qui leur a compliqué la vie non c'était
ça c'était tout ce qu'il y avait avant
donc c'est tout ce qui va venir par
ailleurs le rassemblement national a pas
voté contre ce pacte il s'est abstenu au
Parlement européen mais ça mérite quand
même d'être précisé mais voilà plus
facile à défendre position bien s mais
après Richard a raison ça peut évoluer
souvenez-vous de ce qui s'est passé sur
les voitures les voitures thermiques
finalement le sa alors c'était avant le
vote le vote final mais je les États ont
réussi à se dire CIT pas tenable
première échéance émerger une liste aux
Européennes une liste disons agricole ou
territoire le groupe lot vous savez à
l'Assemblée nationale ce groupe
indépendant a prévu de lancer une liste
donc attendons on pourrait sur ce frontl
avoir quelques surprise sur le modèle de
ce qui s'est passé au Pays-Bas dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et puis alors
petite chose je crois que vous avez tout
à fait raison le pacte vert pour
l'instant il reste quand même largement
en l'air et il y a peu de chance d'être
totalement bouclé avant les européennes
donc il dépendra du Parlement à venir il
y a quand même quelques petits points
qui ont été relativement positifs et
qu'on a oublié en France c'est l'Europe
qui vient d'autoriser le glyphosate on
me dirait manque de bol il est interdit
en France mais quand même tout n'est pas
toujours si mauvais au niveau européen
et ça ça doit faire hurler quelques
téléspectateurs qui
sont
attendez le glyphosate est une obstion
Française le glyphosate est largement
utilisé et il peut même être utilisé de
manière positive pour l'environnement
parce que le glyphosate ça sert à quoi
c'est un dsherbant si vous ne désherbez
pas vous êtes obligé de faire des
labours de plus en plus profonds donc
vous utilisez beaucoup plus de fioule
donc vous avez une une une pratique
beaucoup plus carboné que si vous
utilisez du glyphosate le glyphosate
bien utilisé alors est-il cancér igène
il y a une étude qui dit qu'il est
potentiellement cancérigène comme
d'ailleurs de consommer de il y en a
plusieurs on a on a fait un débat sur ce
thème on avait des agriculteur qui
disait qu'effectivement il utilisait à
minima en France en tout cas et que il y
avait pas vraiment d'alternative pour je
reprends leurs arguments dernière chose
avant de pleurer sur l'absence de
mobilisation des Français pour ces
européensnes peu d'intérêt les partis et
notamment le parti présidentielle a pas
été fichu désigner encore une tête de
liste on est à on est à 5 mois de
l'élection bien sûr pour des raisons de
stratégie individuelle ils sont pas
capables d'avoir un porte-voix un peu
fort qui dit aux gens c'est la campagne
européenne et VO voici les enjeux
important les sociau-démocrates le PS
n'a pas été fichu de désigner encore sa
tête de
liste pas officiel tout ça est en l'air
les seuls qui l'ont fait c'est le
rassemblement national le parti d'Éric
Zemmour et puis les
écolos et les républain depuis une
semaine dernier thème on va parler du du
ministre de l'Agriculture Marc F je
propose deux éléments d'abord évidemment
il se démultiplie un peu partout sur sur
le terrain depuis quelques jours comme
ce samedi dans dans un élevage laitier
il était dans le Cher regardz cet
échange avec avec une
agricultrice va falloir quand même aller
très vite parce que là au vite où on va
on a très peu d'installation euh les
gens quittent ou vont
faire donc on est au bout du bout donc
on nen peut plus je veux dire on a
beaucoup de suicide je veux dire les P
d'amocl auudessus de la têteou lâchez-
nous l chez-nous franchement on peut
plus c'est vra qu'on est en colère et
alors on va écouter sa réponse dans sa
réponse il pointe notamment pas
seulement mais notamment la
responsabilité de la grande distribution
on peut pas avoir des gens qui en
permanence sur des plateaux de
télévision vous expliquent que le bon
prix c'est le bas prix et après qui
disent et qu'il fasse des grandes actes
de déclaration et d'amour à
l'agriculture l'agriculture elle a un
cou et si elle a un cout elle doit elle
doit trouver un prix sinon à la fin il y
aura plus de produits français qui
seront proposés au consommateurs
français donc ça va être un choc qui
doit être me semble-til
Mathieu vous avz tout à l'heure qu'il
était presque démonétisé le ministre de
l'Agriculture est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord Philip chalmain non parce que
moi je trouvais que jusque là il avait
fait un parcours plutôt positif y
compris par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs il a alors effectivement
vous l'avez dit il y a une loi qu'il
avait promis qu'il a reculé et cetera
bon on a on souffre quand même un peu en
France d'un excès et d'une sorte de de
diarrée législative et cetera là en la
matière la loi qui est prévue sur
justement l'installation des jeunes et
la relève elle allait plutôt dans le bon
sens fallait-il la reculer pour intégrer
des éléments de simplification
administrative j'en suis même pas sûr
parce qu'à mon avis ça ne relève pas de
la loi mais bon c'est difficile ça a
toujours été difficile d'être ministre
de l'Agriculture surtout dans ces
moments-là et surtout malheureusement
quand des gens vous disent faites-nous
de bons prix et là où je ne le suis pas
totalement c'est quand il dit c'est la
faute de la grande distribution
non c'est pas la faute de l'industrie
c'est pas la faute de la grande
distribution
malheureusement les systèmes agricoles
aujourd'hui sont des systèmes instables
et comme on l'a dit d'ailleurs au tout
début de notre débat les consommateurs
euxmêmes sont-ils prêt à faire la
différence et à payer un plus qualitatif
qui permettrait de sortir de ces marchés
de matières premièresah ça c'est pas
évident c'estexemple qu'on donnait tout
à l'heure pour le lait mais j'y reviens
pas Richard ver vouz intervenir oui
la difficulté de Marc fen c'est qu'il
est sans doute dans le dans un des
ministères où encore une fois Emmanuel
Macron je dirais presque n'a pas
grandchose à dire Emmanuel Macron ne
pense pas à le monde paysan il la
conférence de presse la semaine dernière
il en a très il ne la pense pas et
j'irais presque jusqu'à penser que ça ne
l'intéresse pas beaucoup au début sous
son premier mandat il y avait Julien de
Normandie ministre de l'Agriculture qui
avait l'avantage d'être un très proche
d'Emmanuel Macron donc de ce fait il y
avait la porte ouverte à ce n pas le cas
de il est là pour des raisons de
distribution de poes Politi donc je
crains pour les agriculteurs et c'est
sans doute aussi ça qu'il met en colère
c'est qu'ils ne se sentent pas
représentés et peut-être même pas comme
intéressant pour le sommet de l'État et
dans un moment très symbolique et de
communication ça peut être très
difficile à vivre avec un enjeu on l'a
dit le le l'enjeu du renouvellement de
génération l' nerveau ils sont
particulièrement vieillissant les les
les agriculteurs français c'est c'est
vraiment des beaucoup de de plus de 60
ans qui vont passer la main dans les
dans les années à venir oui tout à fait
on sait que c'est le sujet du projet de
loi là qui est dans dans les tuyaux mais
pour revenir sur ce qu' vient de dire à
l'instant on a le sentiment
effectivement que ce ministre est resté
discret peut-être trop alors que la
crise couvait depuis plusieurs mois AC y
avait les panneaux les panneaux
signaltiques qui ét panneau ce geste
très intéressant d'une d'une révolte
symbolique et silencieuse hein mais
qu'on a pu observer dans plein de
régions de France les les les panneaux
d'entré dans les villages qui étaient
retournés pour symboliser cette France
qui qui marche à l'envers qui marche sur
la tête c'était quand même un signe
assez fort alors bien moins voyant bien
sûr que des voitures qui brûlent ou des
écoles ou des mairies incendiées mais
tout de même très significatif et les
signaux n'ont pas été peut-être traité à
temps merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous dis
à bientôt sur Public Sénat